- What are your most
fond memories of Idol?
Because people always ask
me about "American Idol"
and sometimes I'm like,
sometimes I don't remember.
Like if you think 20 years back
in your career and you go, huh?
- [Justin] Yeah.
- Like some of it's hard.
- Well, it's wild because
we got shot out of a cannon.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I love just being around
and the fact that we were at
the beginning of things, so -
- And we didn't know.
- [Justin] Nobody knew
what was up.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- The stakes weren't super high for us.
- That was pretty cool actually.
- [Justin] Yes, it was.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- And then we got
to hang out so much,
and I can tell you this,
if you ever have the chance to see Kelly
and she ever says, hey, do
you want to play a card game?
Don't.
- I've always been competitive.
- She's a killer.
It was speed.
- Are you talking about speed?
Do you remember, speed?
- Yeah.
I was gonna say speed, yeah.
- Yes.
We would hang out and we would play speed
because there were these
huge swaths of times
and like we would play speed.
- I love speed.
- And I think I may have won twice
in the hundred times
that we played together.
- I love speed.
- [Justin] Yeah, obviously.
- I know, but I feel like I
have natural caffeine going in,
you know, I've always been like.
(Kelly rolling tongue)
You know?
- [Justin] Yeah.
- So it was really my game.
- It was ridiculous.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, and I was like,
I just kept coming back for more.